Uh, we have a very, very
special guest with us today. Um,
I remember reading,
uh,
Charlie monger saying that he didn't
know a smart man who didn't read all the
time and he has characterized
Warren buffet as a learning machine.
The inspiration from there is how does
one become a very effective learner?
What is the science of learning
and a reading Barb's book.
That is exactly what the
book seems to be teaching us.
And I have loved reading her book.
Not only love reading her book,
I could identify that the voice in
that book is the voice of a teacher.
And that resonated a
lot with me personally.
So I'm very glad Barbara is here with
us today. So without further Ado,
ladies and gentlemen,
please join me in welcoming Barb Oakley.
It's such a pleasure to be here and I'd
like to begin by telling you a little
story. Another one. Uh,
this story is about,
well,
I think all of us love to
watch all the people, right?
To tell some greater or lesser extent.
And I love people watching.
And so I have to tell you about this one
guy who was one of the most interesting
people I've ever watched.
And this was when I was working down
in Antartica at Mcmurdo station.
And this guy's name was Neil.
And Neil was this thin wispy little guy
with kind of a high pitch voice and he
had a big head. So we look like the
sort of upside down exclamation point.
And he would kneel,
used to like to do is he liked to pick
up the phone and answer it with a perfect
imitation of the six foot eight
gorilla of a station manager or Brown.
So one day phone rings, you know,
picks it up as you real, hello,
this is art brown speaking,
and it was art brown on
the other end of the line.
So art says,
who the heck is this?
Or more unprintable words
to that effect at Neil says,
why aren't you,
wow,
I'm so glad you've finally
gotten in touch with yourself.
And so that's actually what we're going
to do here today is to help you to get
more in touch with yourself and what
you're doing when you're doing one of the
most important things you
can do as a human being.
And that is to learn new things.
Now to start,
I have to tell you a little bit
about my background and growing up,
I grew up moving all over the place.
By the time I'd hit 10th grade,
I lived in 10 different places.
Now moving around a lot like this has
some benefits but also has some drawbacks
or potential drawbacks.
And one of the things for me was math is
a very sequential topic and if you miss
it anywhere along the line,
right?
Somebody who's a little bit further ahead
and you're at us from a school where
it was a little behind,
all of a sudden you can actually fall off
the bandwagon and then you fallen off.
It's hard to get back on. And that's
what happened to me early on. I,
I fell off the map bandwagon,
just said, I can't do this.
I hate it. I really want
nothing to do with it at all.
Science is the same way.
And so I basically flunked my
way through elementary, middle,
and high school math and science.
And it's really funny
thinking back on it now,
because I'm a professor of engineering
and I publish well in some of the top
journals,
so I do very well as an engineer.
But one day one of my students found out
about my sordid past as a math flunky
and he asked me, he said, how do
it, how would you change your brain?
And I thought, you know, how did I
do it? I mean, looking back on it,
I was just as little kid and I
love animals and I like fluffy,
furry things.
I like to knit and I,
I loved language and studying language.
And at that time it wasn't,
there weren't college loans that were
relatively straightforward to get in.
So I really wanted to learn a language
and I couldn't afford to go to school.
And so how could I study language if
you know, in that kind of situation.
And there was one way I could do it.
I could actually go and learn a language
and get paid for it while I was doing
it. And that was to join the
army. And so that's what I did.
I joined the army and there you see me
looking re incredibly nervous about to
throw a hand grenade.
And I did learn a language.
I learned Russian and I ended up
working out on Russian trawlers,
a severe trawlers up in the Bering sea.
And that's me standing on
a bunch of fish there. Uh,
I can still swear quite well in Russian,
although the rest of the
Russians a little rusty.
But I loved getting,
having adventures and
gaining new perspectives.
And so I also ended up at the South Pole
station in Antarctica and that's where
I met my husband.
So I always say I had to go to the
end of the earth to meet that man.
And I did so, so the, the thing is though,
what I, what, what was going
on was I began to realize that,
you know, I was always interested
in these new perspectives,
but they're always sort of perspectives
that I was kind of comfortable with.
Somehow. You know, and having adventures,
that's sort of a comfortable thing,
but I wasn't actually kind of stretching
myself to really have a totally new
perspective.
I thought back on the engineers
that I've worked with,
west point engineers who who were in
the military and I realized that their
problem solving skills were
in many ways exceptional.
They could think in a way that I couldn't
think. And I thought, you know what,
if I can read these kinds of equations,
like they could read equations.
What if I could in some sense learn the
language that they were able to speak?
Could I actually change my brain to learn
in that way to learn what these people
knew?
And so as I began to try to
answer that student's question,
how did you change your brain?
I started working on a book to kind of
describe what some of these key ideas
work.
And while I was working on this book I,
I did things like I,
I went to rate my professors.com probably
a few of you have been in schools,
realize that that's a pretty good website.
And I,
I looked to see who are the top professors
worldwide teaching subjects like
engineering, math, chemistry,
physics, economics,
a lot of really difficult subjects and
a lot of very relevant subjects as well,
like psychology,
even English.
How did they teach so people could
learn and how did they learn themselves?
And I also reached out to top cognitive
psychologists and neuroscientists.
And my own background also informed this,
I've taught for several decades is an
engineering professor done active research
in active learning.
And so all of these things
kind of combined together.
And what I found that I thought was very
interesting was when I reached out to
all these professors, a lot of the ones
in the stem disciplines in particular,
science,
technology,
engineering and math use these
approaches that might involve things like
metaphor or analogy.
But they were very embarrassed to say
that because other professors would kind
of be like, oh, you're
dumbing things down.
But it was actually something that all
of these top professors used to more
easily communicate the ideas.
It was like this shared handshake.
They all knew how to do it,
but they didn't realize
these other top professors,
we're using the same approaches.
So what I'm going to tell you now is
I'm going to give you some insight.
This,
these are the key ideas related to
learning that all of these people have
discovered.
So first off,
we know that the brain
is really complicated.
So what we're going to do is simplify
it and you can simplify the brain's
operation.
It did two fundamentally different modes.
First one is what I'll call focus mode.
And the second is what I'll call the
diffuse mode. And this is actually,
it relates to the default mode
network and other related,
there's some 24 or 25 so far,
uh,
neural resting states
that have been detected.
And so these,
all of these states all together,
I'll just call the diffuse
mode and what can happen.
I mean,
our best way to really understand these
two different modes as to use a metaphor
and the metaphor we're going to use is
that of a pinball machine and a pinball
machine. You all know how it
works. You just take a, uh, um,
the pinball and you pull back on the
rubber boots are on the plunger and a ball
goes blinking around on the, on the rubber
bumpers. And that's how you get points.
And what we're gonna do is we're going
to take that pinball machine and we're
going to super impose it on the brain.
And you see the brain right here.
Here's a, you know, uh, the little
ears and there's the nose right there.
And what we're going to do,
we're going to take that pinball machine,
we're gonna put it right on the brain.
And there you go.
There's the pinball machine on the brain,
and you can see how you can
pull back on the plunger there.
And you've got all these little pinballs
in their fridge or the rubber bumpers,
and they're all very close together.
So,
so what happens is in
focus mode type thinking,
like what I'm showing right here,
I've got these close together bumpers
and you often have patterns that are
already there.
For example,
if you've already learned how to
multiply and you're trying to do a
multiplication problem,
you would sit in focus mode and you've
got these patterns that are already there
and you think a thought and it takes off
and it moves roughly around the rubber
bumpers along the pathways.
It's already been in before that you've
developed as a consequence of previous
learning.
But what if the pattern you're
trying to think is something new?
What if you already know
about multiplication,
but you've never
encountered division before,
so you're trying to understand this idea
with the concept of limits in Calculus.
How do you go at a completely new idea
that you've never encountered before?
Well,
that's where this other way the brain
works in diffuse mode thinking can
actually be a benefit. Now,
take a look. Here's the diffuse,
the representative of the diffuse mode,
and it's just an analogy,
but it's a very good one
that helps us understand,
look at how far apart
those rubber bumpers are.
When you think a thought in diffuse mode,
the thoughts can range much more widely.
Now you can't think in a tight grain
fashion to actually solve the particulars
of a problem,
but you can at least get to a new sort
of way of thinking about things that you
couldn't have gotten if you were
just in the focus mode. In fact,
sometimes when you're trying to
solve a really difficult problem,
the worst thing you can do is just keep
sitting there and focusing and focusing
on it because you can be up on that
part of the brain, so to speak.
And yet you need to be in a
completely different place.
So the best thing to do when you're really
stuck and frustrated on a problem is
not to keep focusing on it.
You actually need to get in a
very different mode of thinking.
And that's what, uh, that's,
that's what's represented here.
And so what this means practically
for you is you're sitting there,
you're working, hey,
get out, go for a run,
go down and have a go take a shower if
you need to or do something that really
gets your mind totally off it.
Because when you're in this mode,
as long as your attention
is focused on that problem,
you're still in this mode and you can't
get to this way of solving things.
So,
so how can this play out for people?
If you look at this guy right here,
he was Salvador Dali.
He, uh, one of the most brilliant of the
surrealist painters of the 20th century.
He shown here with his pet ocelot Babu.
And what dollar used to do is this,
you'd sit in a chair when he had a
kind of a intractable problem with his
paintings to solve.
You'd sit and he'd relax and relax who ae.
And just as he relax so much, you know,
kind of letting his mind run free,
he have a key in his hand and just as
he'd relax so much that he falls asleep,
the key would fall from his hand.
The clatter would wake him up and off.
He'd go with this new idea
from the diffuse mode,
taking it back to the focus mode where
he could refine and really use them.
So you might think, well, you know,
that's just great for artists.
But what if you're an engineer?
If you're looking at this guy right here,
this was Thomas Edison.
And what Edison used to do,
at least according to legend,
was he'd sit in a chair with ball bearings
in his hand and he'd relax and relax.
And then finally when he'd fall asleep,
the ball bearings would fall from either
his hand and whatever he had in his
very relaxed way,
been thinking about,
he'd be able to take some of those ideas
from that mode and bring them back with
him to the focus mode
where he could refine it,
analyze and come up with some
of those brilliant inventions.
So the lesson for us out
of all of this is this,
the, I'm giving some exemplary
innovators in various fields,
but whenever you're solving a problem,
even if it's a problem that thousands
or even millions of other people have
solved before for you,
it's the very first time that
you've solved that problem.
And you need to use some of these same
creative approaches that these other
brilliant thinkers have used.
And what you want to do,
be aware of is that you can be in focus
mode or you can be in diffuse smoke,
but you can't really,
as far as we know,
unless you're an exceptionally
well trained to monk,
be in both modes at the same time,
so focused or diffuse and you
want to develop both modes.
Diffuse thinking is often not conscious,
but it is also learning.
And so that's why that relaxation
process can also be very important.
Now I just wanted to give
you a quick image here.
This shows some of the brilliant uh,
connectivity of the default mode network.
See all these connections here
between various aspects of the brain.
This is a web for one mode of working,
but focus mode has a very different web.
So if you're only focusing,
you're not making access or getting access
to a lot of the different connections
that are available for you.
That's why going back and forth
between modes can be so very important.
Now it takes time to do
this. You, you, you can't.
That's why you can't sit down and just
solve a difficult problem immediately.
You often have to go back and
forth between the modes and it.
In some sense,
you could almost think of it like this
is a weight lifter and a weightlifter is
take.
He does centrally cram the night before
a big meet and build muscles like that.
It takes time to develop
those muscles in the same way.
the neural scaffold that is
involved in learning and in
new thinking processes.
But I know what you're really thinking.
You may be thinking,
I'm a procrastinator,
I wait. Sometimes I don't like
have time to do stuff. Right?
And so let's talk a little
bit about procrastination.
And sometimes you can be a
really effective human being,
but still procrastinate about some things.
And so in that sense,
there are things to learn to help
improve your productivity and your
effectiveness in what you do.
So procrastination arises
in a very interesting way.
Studies have shown that if you
look at something you don't like,
the pain centers of your
brain actually activate.
So if you look at a book for
a subject you don't like,
you can actually feel a twinge and we
can see it in the brain if you're being
imaged. So, so what do you do
when you feel pain? I mean,
it's the same pain as when you
hammer your thumb with a hammer.
Well, you have two different
ways of handling it.
The first way is you can work through it
like 20 minutes or so and the pain will
gradually disappear.
But if you're like most people,
what you'll do is you'll just
kind of turn your attention away.
Just something more pleasant. And guess
what? You'll feel better immediately,
right?
And so in some sense,
procrastination can actually be
a little bit like an addiction.
You do it once, you do it
twice. It's not that big a deal.
You do it a lot of times though,
and it actually can be very,
very detrimental for your
life. So I'm an engineer. I'm,
I believe in totally practical,
useful things.
So what I'm going to do is cut
right to the chase and say,
here's the most effective way to
help you deal with procrastination.
And it is simply to use,
uh, the pomodoro technique.
And this is a technique that
was developed by Francesco city,
a low in the 1980s and it involves,
he called it the pomodoro technique
because he had a tomato shaped timer and
Pomodoro is Italian for tomato.
And what he would do is he would,
he,
he recommends you set
a timer for 25 minutes.
Actually you can have different
times, different things, uh,
are used different time lengths are,
are useful for different people,
but you set it in general for 25 minutes
and then you turn off everything else.
So no alarms,
no instant messages,
anything that can can
disturb your concentration,
you turn that off and then you work with
is careful of focused attention as you
can for those 25 minutes. Now sometimes
I'll be working away and I'll think,
am I really focusing as hard as I can?
And then I think,
well obviously not because I just got
distracted and I'm wondering whether I'm
focusing instead of actually
working. And so, so,
but I let that thought just drift
by and then I get back to my work,
right? And that's what you're doing in
this technique. You want to just get,
keep your mind on your work.
And what happens is because you're only
focusing on the task and the time and
not the pain of,
I must complete this task,
it's somehow makes it so much
easier to do. I mean anybody,
virtually anybody can sit
for 25 minutes and work. Uh,
and then when you're done,
reward yourself.
And that reward is actually very important
because what you're doing is you're
focusing during the focus mode,
but then you want to train yourself
to relax and enjoy and do something
different. Just, you know, surf the
web, do you know, go out for all day,
whatever floats your boat,
you go off and do that.
And this actually is important because
we know that some aspects of learning
take place during this relaxed process.
So you're,
you're Tencent tendency is to think
I'm not working when I'm not focusing,
but you actually are.
So it kind of gives you a little bit of
a feeling of relief and accomplishment
that it is okay to relax.
So a couple of little little pointers.
First,
don't sit down and do a pomodoro and say,
you know,
I'm going to finish off my work.
Don't focus on the task,
only focus on the time.
And that's the trick to this technique
because I get you past that pain in the
brain and allows you to just relax
comfortably and get into the flow of the
task. The other thing
is don't like say, okay,
I'm going to do 20 pomodoros today and
and think that you're going to beat
yourself into more productivity that way.
I want to just gradually you start getting
used to this technique and you'll see
that it works very,
very well.
Now another aspect that's really important
related to learning is we've often
been told, hey, sleep's really important
before a big test or something like that.
Actually sleep is important
in a lot of different ways.
And I'm going to talk to you.
I just mentioned a little bit of one of,
one of the primary important reasons
that sleep's important for learning.
We've found that if you look at the cells,
these little circles here represent cells,
neurons in the brain.
And what happens when you go
to sleep is this, that well,
when you're awake first when you're awake,
these metabolites will come
out and they'll go in between,
you know the junctions and they kind of
sit out there and they're essentially
toxins in your brain.
So when you're awake,
these toxins are gradually accumulating
in your brain and they affect your
judgment. That's why when you stay awake
a longer and longer time, it's difficult.
It's more and more difficult to think
clearly. So when you go to sleep though,
here's what happens. Now, watch very
carefully to what happens to those cells.
Go to sleep.
They shrink.
I'll do that again cause I
just have some fun doing this.
See they shrink when you go to sleep.
And because they shrink,
what that does is that allows fluids
to wash by the cells and wash these
metabolites out.
So a very important part of
sleep is just the housekeeping,
the cleaning that takes place that allows
your brain to function so much more
effectively.
Now,
another very important aspect of
learning or of sleep relates to neural.
A synoptic growth in this
wonderful paper by Guang Young,
uh,
she's out of Llangollen is if
you look at the top picture,
you can see here what's going on.
This is the same neuron
at the top and the bottom,
the top neuron is before
learning and before sleep.
The bottom neuron is after
learning and after sleep,
all of these little triangles
are new synoptic connections.
And so when you learn
something and you go to sleep,
that's when the new synoptic
connections are forming.
And this is what's going
on when you're learning.
So that's why it's very important when
you're learning something new. Again,
you don't want to cram at the last minute.
You want to have many short
learning periods, sleep, learning,
sleep.
And that's helping you build that neuro
scaffold that helps you learn so much
better. So there's another
thing, aspect of learning.
And people often think this is so
completely disconnected from real learning
that they,
they even are taking away recess
from kids because they're like, God,
that doesn't help them learn only when
they're sitting in front of us learning
from us. That's when they really
learned. But that's not true at all.
We're now finding how incredibly important
exercise is to the learning process.
Now, if you'll look here,
this, uh, study, uh,
was of a mouse and there were training
this mouse to differentiate between two
different symbols.
And if you look in the background,
what's happening is all of these
blue blobs are old neurons.
Now, we used to think you are born
with all the neurons that you have,
and that's what you got for the
rest of your life. Well, of course,
now we know that's not true,
but it was wisdom received
wisdom for many decades.
And so what they found was see these new,
this red,
these red lines here,
those are actually the new neurons that
are being born every day in all of us,
as well as in the smells
in the hippocampus.
And that is how those are absolutely
essential to our ability to learn and
remember new information.
There's two ways to allow these
new neurons to grow and survive.
One is you have you,
you get exposed to new environments.
That's what travel can be so good.
That's what you're learning
can be effective and these
kinds of things can help
those new neurons survive.
But the other way of helping
these new neurons survive,
that's just as powerful as
learning is simply to exercise.
So exercise is profoundly
important, and I'm not talking, hey,
I've got to be an Olympic
weightlifter or be a marathon runner.
Even simple walking can be very,
very effective in help.
And I'm sure you've
all had the experience,
you're all mazy brained and then you go
out for a walk and it clears up your way
of thinking.
But even a few days of an exercise
program is doing much more than that.
It's actually enhancing the ability
of your neurons to grow and survive.
Now, if you look, there's a name
right here, Terence and I'll ski.
He was on one of the original papers,
it doing this original research.
He's the Francis Crick professor at
the Salk Institute and he's also my
colleague in doing the massive
open online course that's based on,
uh, based on the book. And Terry is,
he's a remarkable guy and it was really
a lot of fun making them massive open
online course with him. And so, so we
went and we did some filming together.
And so then I asked and I
said, well, Terry, you know,
you're talking all this stuff
about the importance of exercise.
Do you exercise what you do? And
he's like, dude, why you exercise?
And what he does is he, he goes and, uh,
every day or every few days he goes down,
he's like a mountain goat. The Guy 65
means like climbs down and you know,
I'm scrambling after him and he goes,
you know,
running on the beach just like you see
here. And this is how he gets his access.
I love how he finishes here. Watch
this, look at that. Yeah. So,
so he is a legend in neuroscience and
I'm convinced that part of it is because
he uses some of these ideas that he's
found in his research to help him really
keep his edge intellectually.
Now.
So let's just talk a little bit about
something called working memory.
Working memory is how you
keep a brief thought in mind.
It used to be thought that you had seven
slots in working memory and that's why
you could hold a phone
number of seven numbers.
But now we're kind of realizing it's
more like maybe there's four slots in
working memory. So maybe for me
it's like two slots and right.
But anyway, so you have four
slots and it's in your prefer.
You can kind of think of
it as your working memory.
You're holding things in
your prefrontal cortex.
So I've got to kind of symbolize right
there as you're forced lots of working
memory.
So when you are remembering something
or thinking about something with working
memory,
you can think of it symbolically at
least as something like an octopus,
the octopus of attention that reaches
through those slots of working memory and
makes connections between different ideas.
And that's why you can't hold too many
ideas at once in your brain before you
get all confused.
But,
but what happens if you're multitasking,
right?
What happens if you're kinda got a
little bit of an eye out here on some,
you know,
am I getting an instant message?
In some sense that's like taking one
of those tentacles away of your working
memory.
You don't have a lot of tentacles.
So it really is kind of actually making
whatever intellectual heft you have,
you're kind of losing some of it.
You're getting a little stupider
when you're multitasking.
So that's why careful focused
attention is so incredibly important,
especially when you're working on
something that's rather difficult. Now,
I'd just like to contrast
this with the diffuse mode.
The diffuse mode is it's,
it's a lot of connections,
but they're much more random
in how they take place.
So how do you take something from
working memory into long term memory,
which is more distributed
around in your brain? Well,
the best way is through practice.
Practice makes in some sense permanent.
The more you practice,
the more the broader that
little neural pathway the uh,
becomes and the more
deeply embedded it becomes.
So if you're learning something and you
practice those patterns get deeper and
deeper,
and that's how you can learn something
and draw it from working memory or from
longterm memory into working memory.
If you don't practice,
what's going to happen is you've got
those neurons and it's almost like you've
got these little metabolic vampires,
it just come and they suck those patterns
away before they can get deepened.
And so that's why sometimes you can
learn something from a professor.
You even understand it. You've had that
great stroke of insight. You walk away,
you don't look at it for a few days,
and those little metabolic fat
vampires just suck that pattern away.
And you can't really remember
or understand what you
had learned previously.
So the best way to get patterns,
well embedded in your longterm memory,
it's the practice through
spaced repetition.
So you might practice Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday, maybe at again on Friday.
And and by spacing things out,
you realize now that you're getting those
new synoptic connections growing every
time you learn a little
and then you sleep on it.
What you don't want to do is this kind
of thing where you're just kind of
cramming like crazy and then look that
metabolic vampire just kind of sucks it
all away and you're left with very little.
It's hard to remember
what you were learning.
A good way to think about this is
just the analogy of a of a wall.
If you're building a brick wall and you
give yourself time between layers of
mortar, it can set and you can
build a solid, sturdy wall.
But if you don't,
it's all kind of a jumble and it doesn't
turn into a really good structure that
you can actually use.
So let's go back again and we're going
to talk a little bit more quickly about
attention and how it affects working and
the relationship with working memory.
Now if you look here,
you can see you've got one slot in your
working memory that's filled when you
have one slot filled. You could put
other things in your working memory,
but,
but here's the trick.
How do you get things into just one slot?
It turns out that if you create a chunk,
one chunk of the material,
it's easy to pull into working memory.
So here's what I mean by that.
If you look at here, here's a, a
raw pattern of information, right?
It's a puzzle. It's hard to figure
out. It looked like a mad scramble,
but once and look what's going
on in your working memory,
it's kind of going a little crazy
trying to figure things out. In fact,
recent research,
uh,
at Stanford has shown children who
are trying to learn math facts.
It's their low prefrontal cortexes
are going crazy as they try to,
uh,
assimilate and master the material.
But once they've got those
math facts down, this relaxes.
What's actually happening is this,
they've got the essential idea and this
what that essential idea is like is one
smooth single ribbon.
They can easily pull into working
memory when they need to in order to
understand and make connections with
other problems that they're trying to
solve.
Now if you just memorize and you're not
understanding what you're memorizing,
it's like creating that little
circle there and, and Eh,
you can see it, you've got
it. It really is a chunk,
but you can't fit it very
well with other chunks.
So there's another important idea
about chunking and that's this.
Once you've compressed and idea,
that's one of the most brilliant
mathematicians was mentioning,
one of the great aspects of math is
simply that idea that you can compress it
when you grapple,
grapple,
grapple and all of a sudden it
clicks and you've got to compress.
Once you've got a compressed in a chunk,
there's actually,
you can make that chunk bigger,
right?
And just like learning
a little piece of song,
you can actually learn another
piece and join them together.
And you've got a bigger chunk or you
can also learn similar chunks of other
disciplines and it's very, very
helpful. That's an idea of transfer.
But what you're really doing when you're
learning and mastering a topic is you
are in some sense creating a library of
chunks and you can draw on that library
and make connections between things.
And that's how great creative,
uh, creativity arises, is making
connections with those chunks.
So true experts often have
enormous libraries of chunks
that they've developed.
Now when you're learning,
there's sort of a,
you can think of it as there's
a top down approach. So if,
if you're learning a new topic,
you can almost think of it like,
look at,
there's a chunk there that's that tire
and here's a chunk fits the man's face
and another tire.
So you're learning all these chunks and
when you get them all kind of learned,
it forms the big picture of the material.
Even if you're missing a
few pieces here and there,
you still got that big picture.
But if you don't practice and repeat
and really master your chunks,
it's like this.
It's like you're trying to put together
the big picture with chunks that are
faint and it's much harder to put together
the big picture with that in mind.
So again,
as I was saying,
you've got a one ribbon right of thought.
That's a chunk here is uh,
another chunk in another field,
but it's of a similar shape and
that's the idea of transfer.
So if you're a physicist,
you may be able to learn economics more
easily because some of the chunks are
really similar in their shape.
If you are a language learner and
you're learning math and science,
there are medic chunks available.
For example,
that idea of practice and repetition for
language also applies in learning math
and science.
So,
so let's go to some other aspect
I think relates to learning.
Some of you may say, ah, some of you
may have wonderful memories here,
but some of you may wish you
had better memories. Well,
let me kind of give you a little
awareness where you think maybe a negative
attribute actually can be a very,
very positive attribute.
It turns out that when you
have a poor working memory,
what that really means is you can't
hold things in mind very well, right?
So you're looking at your colleague who
can remember all this different stuff.
They can hold it in their working memory,
turn somersaults with it,
and come up with new ideas really quickly
and you're lucky to remember what they
were even talking about.
But here's the thing.
Research has shown that if you
have a poor working memory,
you'll near four slots
are like pretty weak.
Other stuff is already
s always slipping in.
That's why you can't hold
ideas very well in your mind,
but because the other
stuff is slipping in,
you're actually more
creative and it should.
Research show has shown that if you
have attention deficit disorder or your
attention wanders, oh, shiny,
then then what happened?
What that means is you have much
more potential for being creative.
Do you have to work harder than some
other people in order to make up for that?
Yeah,
you do.
But that that comes with the trade off,
that you are highly
creative so you can be very,
very valuable in your job even though
you may have to work harder sometimes to
have that, uh, achievement.
Now you may say,
well that's all well and good, but
I'm actually a slow thinker, right?
I see these other people and they've
got like a super race car brain.
They can pick up these ideas so fast
and I kind of move along more slowly.
Well, one of my heroes in, um,
in the history of science is the Nobel
Prize winners, Santiago Ramonica Hall,
who's known as the father
of modern neuroscience.
Ramonica hall was not a genius
and he said, so himself,
part of what he did was he
worked hard and was persistent,
but he said these people
with race car brains,
which he was not often race along,
and they jump to conclusions
that he didn't miss.
He would see them and he was
more flexible in his thinking.
When he'd see a mistake,
he would go, wait a minute.
Whereas the race car driver is so
used to being right and being fast,
that they're much less able
to be persistent and to
flexibly change in the light
of contradictory data.
So if you have a, um,
you know, a slow brain,
think of it like this,
there's the person with
the race car brain, great,
but you're the hiker and your
experience is completely different.
You walk along, you can see the little
rabbit trails that they've missed.
You can reach out and touch the pine
needles, you can smell the pine forests.
All of this is missed
by the race car driver.
So your way of thinking can be
exceptionally valuable as well.
In fact,
Miriam Merce cause Amir's a Connie was,
she won the fields medal, which is
the top award in mathematics, uh,
the equivalent for mathematics
of the Nobel prize.
And she was told as a young person,
you think too slowly to be a
mathematician. Well guess what?
She's one of the most
creative mathematicians alive.
So if you think slowly,
more power to you,
yeah, you're doing good.
Now I also want to bring up another uh,
aspect and that is the aspect
of the imposter syndrome.
This is so important. It's so
common that and, and what it is,
it's a feeling like you're
the fake in the room, right?
I'm working here,
maybe I'm working at Google and I'm really
not as good as they say that I am and
I, I'm kind of an imposter here and
people feel this all over the world.
No matter what they're doing. You're a
professor, oh wait a minute. You know,
they're going to find out what the real
truth is. I took a test and I did well,
but next time I'm not going to fail it
because I know they'll find out what the
real truth is. Really,
really common feeling.
And the best way to address the imposter
syndrome is to just be aware how common
it is.
So next time you have a thought,
like I don't really not
as good as they say. I am.
Remember that the imposter syndrome
talking and the probably one of the most
important things that I could bring up.
And so that's why I'm doing it towards
the end here is this idea of illusions of
competence in learning.
Now,
let's say that suddenly for some reason
a bear came hurdling out of this screen
and rampaging through the room,
would you feel a surge of adrenaline
and nervous energy? I mean,
suddenly you're,
your body would react physiologically
to this feeling of intense fear as you
realize that the bear was actually
in front of you. But the thing is,
when you think about learning situations,
we often say, students will
come up and say, you know,
I have test anxiety.
That's why I didn't do well on this test.
But for a lot of students,
sadly,
sitting down and looking at a test
is like, there's a bear there.
They just realized at that moment that
they really didn't know the material even
though they thought they did. So, uh,
students and people can fool themselves
that they're learning something when
they're actually not learning something.
So I'll give you some of the best
ways for truly learning something.
First off,
tess are the best.
Test yourself on everything all the time,
the same hour spent testing as
opposed to that hours spent studying.
You will learn far more by
taking a test and use flashcards.
Flashcards are not just for
language learners, right? Why?
Why let them have all the fun flashcards
or for ordinary for learning in math
and science. For example,
if you talk to great poets,
what great poets will tell you is
memorize the poem because you'll feel the
passion and the power of
the poem much more deeply.
Why should mathematicians not
be able to share in this fun?
How about engineers?
When we have equations,
if you memorize the equation and really
look at what does it mean while you're
doing that,
it actually can bring out the
richness of what you're learning.
And another thing is when you're
having homework, homework,
a lot of times people make the
mistake of thinking, Hey, you know, I,
I did my homework problem and it's like
saying I'm learning the piano and I
played this piano piece one time
and uh, and so I've got it. Well,
nobody does that when they're
learning a musical instrument.
And in the same way when you're studying,
you don't want to just do
a homework problem once,
you don't have time to do all of them
and kind of repeat them, the pig,
some of the key ones and
see if you can do it again,
like practice it and
maybe do it in your mind.
Can you step through all the steps?
If you can play it almost
like a song in your mind,
you've really got it.
You've got it down as a chunk and
that can help build things now, uh,
build your knowledge of the material.
Now,
probably the most valuable technique
when you're learned trying to really
understand something difficult is simple.
Recall when you're reading
material on a page,
you read away and your tendency is to,
well, I'm going to underline it right?
Because when your hand
is moving on the page,
you think it's moving it into your
brain somehow. But it actually is not.
So resist the urge.
You can do a little bit of a underlining,
but it's better to write it because
you're helping to neurally encode these
ideas.
And then when you read the page,
simply look away and
see what you can recall.
That as it turns out,
is very powerful in building
your understanding of the
material in a way that
other techniques,
including mine mapping and rereading,
they're not nearly as good as recall.
So if,
uh,
another very important aspect is simply
to study judiciously with other people
or talk about what you're trying
to understand with other people.
Now this has to be done judiciously.
Obviously you don't,
all learning does not take
place in a cooperative fashion.
Sometimes you have to go off,
but when you're learning
something sort of in focus mode,
there's a part in parcel of that focus
mode and that is a feeling that what
you've just learned is correct,
right?
This sort of rightness feeling.
And the only way you can really disabuse
yourself sometimes is to go off and
bounce your ideas off of other people
and they can almost serve like a greater
kind of diffuse mode to help disabuse
you when you do make mistakes.
So judicious studying with friends and,
and conversation with colleagues
can be incredibly helpful.
Also explain in a way that a
10 year old can understand.
So frequently we explain electricity,
the flow of electricity as water,
the flow of water. It's an analogy,
it breaks down all analogies breakdown.
But,
but Richard Fineman,
the Nobel prize winning physicist
used to go around and challenge top
mathematicians in the world
to explain in a silly way,
like in a way that their grandmothers
could understand what they were doing and
you know what they could.
So this means that no matter how difficult
that problem is that you're working
on,
if you find a way to explain it,
simply you'll be able to
understand it much more deeply.
One thing to do is insert yourself
into whatever the problem is.
Like here I am in a a a
copper matrix, right? Uh,
if Barbara Mcclintock the,
uh,
the Nobel prize winning a geneticist
used to kind of imagine herself down at a
genetic level so she could understand
and see how the genes might actually be
operating. So that's a trick that's often
used by some of the greatest thinkers.
Try to find a way to get yourself into a,
almost like a play,
whatever you're trying to understand.
If you want some more information about
what the, what I've talked about here,
there's much more in the book of mine
for numbers and there's a lot more and
it's all free in the massive open online
course for Coursera through Uc San
Diego.
Learning how to learn.
And that is the key,
except for one thing,
like to leave you with this last thought.
We're often thought told
that follow your passion,
that is the key to everything.
Just follow your passion and your life
will really be a better place for it.
We're told that,
but some things,
your passion develops about what you're
really good at and some things take much
longer to get good at.
So don't just follow your passions,
broaden your passions and your
lives will be greatly enriched.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible]
now we'll open it up for a
few questions for bar. Uh,
please raise your hand if
you have a question and I'll
bring the mic over to you.
So one of the questions I had
was that, um, I, you know, when,
whenever learning things and tackling
tough problems, people always say, well,
we'll break it down into smaller
parts that you know how to do.
And so I wondered how that fits into
the focus and diffuse mode because that
seems kind of like breaking a diffuse
problem into a bunch of focus problems.
It actually, what that really
relates to is that idea of chunks.
So remember that you've got
four slots and working memory.
The more you can understand
one simple part of it, right?
And make it into a chunk and then another
little aspect of it and make that into
a chunk and then another one.
And then so you're focusing to do that.
And then in diffuse mode,
you're reaching up above and making the
connection randomly when you're sleeping
out for a walk, taking a shower,
all these kinds of things. So, uh,
so they all are related.
But actually that's great advice if
you try and learn it all at once,
it's so overwhelming.
It's like you're a little prefrontal
cortex is scrambling madly,
but it's overwhelmed.
So you want to just get a piece of it
so you can draw that up as a ribbon.
Very good question.
A chunk requires understanding. So when
there was a chunk where there is a,
that means that there was an experience
of understanding that led to that.
Not necessarily you can learn a word
in a language and you can not know what
that word means.
And you can learn a lot of words in a
language but not know what that means.
So,
but if you do know what they mean,
it actually can make it easier to remember
that word and easier to chunk that
word and easier to use those
chunks to put together sentences.
So,
uh,
so for the most part we always want
chunking to involve understanding as well.
But technically, no, you don't
have to have understanding.
It's just the understanding helps
to kind of knit things together, uh,
so that you can remember them more easily.
For example,
if I'm trying to learn the
word doc as Pato in Spanish,
um, Kay, if I'm just going Pato,
I'm trying to remember that word.
I don't have any understanding of what it
means. It's kind of harder to remember.
But if I know the Pato means doc,
I can say what if I'm trying to remember
read by having a little Pato that my
duck is floating in and that can help
serve as that understanding helps serve as
a bridge to get it into my mind.
So that very,
that's a really good question because
people often think, oh, you build a chunk.
It's automatic that you understand it.
Not necessarily a,
but it's a very good thing
to have for the most part.
Okay.
I went to ask you,
you mentioned that people who've mastered
one area can find it easier to learn
another area because
they are related chunks.
It depending on how close theory is,
if you learn Icelandic,
you're probably going to be able to
learn German more easily. But, uh, it's,
it may help a little bit with some of
the metacognitive skills as far as when
you're learning Chinese,
but they're so very different that um,
it's only those metacognitive sort
of things that might help, uh,
with Martinez stole a little
bit of an aspect of fundamental,
how do you structure a language that I
think is common to all languages? Um, so,
uh,
so it depends on how close things are.
But what's I think is fascinating
is that you never know.
That's why it's so important to have
people coming from one field to a very
different field. Right? You,
you're a deep sea diver and you go into
nursing and you actually can bring so
really good ideas and the best ideas are
often developed by two different types
of people.
One is someone who's very young,
so they haven't been sort of
indoctrinated into this is how you think.
But the other is outsiders,
people who are trained in a different
discipline who come and take an initial
look and have fresh eyes
at what they're seeing.
So good questions.
Thanks.
Maybe a more practical thing,
I'm curious about your opinion.
If you're familiar with that, with a,
the effort everyday math curriculum,
which a lot of schools are teaching
now, which, uh, for example,
my kids take and uh, it, for
example, when they teach math,
they emphasize getting a sort of,
almost like a number theory feel like
they learn like four different ways to
multiply instead of one, you know,
the way we learned it. So for example,
with my kids,
they're incredibly by this,
I'm just wondering if you're familiar
with it. If you have a, you know,
how does it fit into this? And like
if you think that's it have opinions.
It's, it's different in
different parts of the country.
And so I'm out in Michigan,
we have different techniques.
It depends,
I think it depends on the kids.
For some kids it's great to learn all
these different techniques for other kids,
you know,
just get one method down really well
and then you can climb up from there.
My own personal opinion is one of the
best math supplement programs is simply
Kumon mathematics. And I'm
not a paid spokesperson for
coming in mathematics. So,
but what they,
um,
what they do is they have simple
methods of practice and repetition.
They help build mastery in your learning
of mathematics and they don't give you
a bunch of different methods. They just
make sure you know how to multiply,
you know,
how to divide and uh,
and you really know
how to do these things.
So I guess my godsons and I haven't
really encountered that question before,
is I think I prefer to see someone
really learn it well using one technique.
When you're older you can see other ways,
but if you've got that
one way really good,
you got it and you can move up. Uh,
but if you're learning too many,
it can be quite confusing.
I suppose it would be the equivalent
of your growing up morning,
eight languages at once. You
know, some kids can handle it,
but for one kid said,
might be a little bit confusing to
have too much going on at one time,
especially about one thing.
Okay.
Have a question around reading,
um, and not like math or something.
But if I'm reading say a philosophy
book by Nietzsche Heidegger for example,
which is 400 pages long and I'm a slow
reader and I'm assuming I'm a very
focused reader because I do grasp and
retain what I have read pretty well,
but I'm incredibly slow.
So do you have any methods to figure out
how to be a fast reader but at the same
day and be able to retain and
deeply grasp what I'm reading?
Um,
the short answer is no.
Research has lately shown that our
techniques for speed reading or actually
they're a little bit,
it seems somewhat spurious or
to read anything difficult,
more deeply simply takes time.
My,
I always think in the back of my mind,
stem disciplines, science, technology,
engineering, math is, is really
difficult for a lot of people.
But then there's philosophy that's I
think one of the hardest things in general
for people to really,
it's incredibly important,
but it's difficult.
And I think just having a
little understanding and
compassion for yourself that
you're actually tackling among
humankind's most difficult topics.
And if it's slow,
uh,
well you're doing fantastic.
Cause I would be the same way and I
think a lot of people are really the same
way.
There's some probably super fast Maserati
brain thinkers who could buzz right
through that stuff, but they would
miss things that you would see.
I've been wondering how your techniques
actually apply more generally to kits
and you briefly touched
actually on a previous question,
practice and repetition,
but more concretely,
how do you get actually kids interested
in mathematics so that they keep on
practicing?
The way that we've been teaching kids is
it's like let's get them introduced to
the fun stuff.
We're going to have them hands on and
we're going to have him dropping eggs and
doing all this exciting stuff and then
they get to college and they hit calculus
and it's like the death march,
right?
They start dropping like flies
because they're not used to that.
Everything's always been fun,
right?
So we don't do that when we're
teaching things like music.
We don't do that when we're
teaching foreign languages,
but students fall in love with those
subjects because they can gain the
expertise in part through some drudging
through practice and repetition.
So I think part of the reason that we
have so many kids in this country fall off
the bandwagon is we try to make
everything really exciting and really fun.
And we forget the lessons that language
learners and musicians and sports people
in sports dance instructors,
they'll know their practice.
And repetition is part
of gaining expertise.
And when we get that incorporated
back into the curriculum, it's there,
but it's not nearly as sound as
it is in many other countries,
which is why I think we see so many
people coming to this country with a love
and a mastery of learning in science
and in mathematics that is not growing
organically because we're not introducing
kids in the United States to some of
these ideas of the, also the supplemental
importance of practice and repetition.
Um, so those are my thoughts.
We do do a little bit of it,
but really not enough
because for a long time,
sadly there's been this feeling that
too much practice and repetition of
mathematics will kill your
creativity instead of the reality,
which is every great expert has to
have practice and repetition with what
they're learning. So, uh, so
those are my thoughts on that.
Thank you.
So understanding is important
and conduct is important.
And speaking of that,
uh,
so is there a could be like top down
approach and [inaudible] approach.
Uh,
so what do you think is better?
Is it better to understand the big picture
and then try to like study subject or
it's better to like study this small
chunks and build this understanding like
from,
or maybe we have to mix it.
You've got it exactly right.
You don't want to be just doing small
things all the time and you don't want to
be perched overhead all the time.
You want to be, it's hard to get.
What is the big picture when you're,
you learn one little chunk and
you learn another little chunk,
but you want to start piecing that into
the big picture as much as you can and,
and so, so you want to be
kind of going back and forth.
One of the techniques that I didn't talk
about that's very important is that of
interleaving. And a lot of times
when you're learning, for example,
um, some new technique and
capitalists, you'll do 10 problems,
uh, uh, pretty much the same, uh,
in learning that
technique and in Calculus.
But you don't want to do that.
You want to do one or two
problems using that technique,
flip to another section of the book.
Do that problem kind of compare,
wait a minute, why am I using this
technique here and that technique here?
Why are those different?
Flip back, do another one of
the first technique is look,
do a different,
we're not training people,
we don't even have our books set up to
interleave and we need to start doing
that because that's what actually it's
practicing repetition but mixed with
interleaving the bills,
flexibility.
So those are my thoughts on that.
Good question.
Like when I was in high school and college
and taking math, I was perfectly fine.
Like, you know, I did well
and did well on the test,
but my problem was always trying to
apply it outside that environment,
like trying to use it practically or in
everyday life or whatever it was that I
needed certain math skills for.
I just could never do it.
And I was wondering if you had any sort
of technique or strategy or ideas about
how there's a way to take math from the
school and sort of be able to apply it
in regular life or just outside of school?
So that's a very good question.
One of the,
what are the things that
people do when they're there?
They look at math and they say, how
am I ever gonna use this? In fact,
I remember one was called
into the principal's office
in eighth grade. And uh,
because I wasn't doing my math,
I was actually reading a book.
And so I Rehmann stay straight in with
the principals saying that there was no
real use for it. I would never use it.
And you know, and they gave up on me that,
that point. But it's kind of
like this when you're, um,
when you're at the gym and you're lifting
a specific type of weight or are you
ever going to go to the,
uh,
go into the outside world and lift
that kind of weight? Of course not.
But you're actually using muscles that
you might use related muscles when you're
lifting up, uh, uh, your luggage to
get in and put it in the airline,
our compartment.
So what you're doing when you're learning
something in math and science is your
developing sort of neural pathways.
You may not use exactly that one,
but in surprising ways they can shape
how you're thinking about things.
So an example is this, they did
a study and they found, you know,
there's some kids who,
who go through all the way through college
and you can kind of take courses that
have almost no math really involved,
you know,
math for poets or you know,
these kinds of courses and
you go all the way through.
But people who have this kind of
background where they've had very little
exposure,
when you control for all aspects of
what's going on that you can reasonably
control for the ones who have no real
background in math are far more likely to
default on their home mortgages.
So you don't think about that,
but it's actually you're able to think
more intelligently. Now what about,
um, you're really concerned
about the environment. So, uh,
so someone comes up and says, well,
we've got to have electric cars. Um,
sounds really good. Right?
But if you're trained you,
you've got some kind of background,
you could go, yeah, but wait a minute.
What about the effective batteries
on the environment? Right?
Do they actually make more pollution?
In fact,
does that transfer of energy create more
harm for the environment than a regular
gasoline engine?
If you're taught to think a little bit
more rationally and carefully about
things,
you can actually,
you're using those intellectual muscles
in ways that you haven't really,
you don't really realize how
important that actually is.
So w one way though,
uh,
just reflecting just a little
bit of a different way.
Cause your questions very deep.
When you're learning a language,
one of the things you do is you're,
you're learning, you're practicing AI.
It can be really tough to actually go
and meet somebody and talk with them,
right?
Who speaks that language.
But that real life experience is what
brings the language alive and what
nourishes the desire to learn it.
So I think finding ways,
when you're walking around and you're
thinking about something you just learned
mathematically,
look around and try and bring it into
the environment you're in a and think
about trying to think about it in those
ways. That's such a great question, uh,
because it,
it helps us be aware,
the richness of life around us.
And so I think trying to
bring some of his ideas,
you're learning into
the life around us is,
is a brilliant thing to do
in a great attitude to have.
So I thank you so very
much for having me here.
Fantastic talk. Thank
you so much. Thank you.
[inaudible].